oh savannah
i can't even good morning
savannah guthrie can't believe she
accidentally overslept you don't have
much time to stew
talk about a complete nightmare the
today show anchor seemingly missed her
morning alarm for work and documented
her delay on instagram
[Music]
it's a race to hair and makeup for
savannah who shows up to set about 20
minutes before the show goes live
thankfully the glam team works their
magic and has savannah in her chair with
literally seconds to spare
okay this
is a miracle
i'm gonna make it
yep savannah makes it to her seat by the
skin of her teeth
i can't believe ten seconds for local
and we're gonna make the tease oh yeah
it's amazing wow
but she's not off the hook with her
co-anchor craig melvin who calls her out
at the top of the show hoda's got the
morning off you almost had the morning
office stop well guthrie rolled in about
15 minutes ago she overslept she is
normal she's normal 15 minutes ago with
no hair no makeup it was a terrifying
sight but some miracle workers upstairs
rolled me in and i'm very happy to be
here we've all been there so of course
sg's on-air crew had to use her rough
start to kick off a conversation about
the challenges of being on the early
ship
maybe you had a bit of an alarm clock i
know it was crazy about that wasn't even
an hour ago that was like 35 minutes ago
no hair no makeup just a big old mess
people always ask us you know in morning
television do you ever sleep not very
often no not very often i guess but yeah
you mean i can't believe it it's a
miracle i'm so happy to be here good
morning
but this wouldn't be savannah's first
relatable mishap this year back in march
the 50 year old broadcaster showed up
pretty comfy to work wearing fuzzy house
slippers to host the show after
experiencing an injury she explained on
instagram quote sprained toe silver
lining doing the show in slippers i may
never go back i feel like the today show
really shines and i'm so proud to get to
be a part of it and while savannah is a
total pro at her job she told et back in
april she sometimes falls short just
like anyone else
we do the daily news we do our best
sometimes we mess it up
and then there's a new day and we get to
try again
[Music]